au même titre que tu dois être dans la
cuisine ma fille et tu dois faire leur
passage à beyrouth terre le gars à cette
pression sociale totale qui dit que tu
dois rouler des mécaniques être costaud
porter le foyer
[Musique]
j'ai été élevé de la manière ou de cette
manière là où on dit à un garçon je peux
pas aller faire de la danse tu peux pas
aller faire du théâtre ou de la chanson
parce que c'est pour les filles y avait
peu de peu le droit à 7 à une certaine
sensibilité en étant un garçon je devais
avoir les épaules fortes dur pour rien
pour marcher dans la boue et pas pleurer
alors que moi j'étais en douillet
marcher dans la boue
je détestais ça je jouais le jeu 2-2 du
du bonhomme qu'on attendait de mon
apparence je crois j'ai eu du garçon en
tout cas qu'on attendait de moi en
apparence donc en bas de chez moi quand
j'étais à créteil je tenais les épaules
je vous hais le mec et je jouais ça
m'allait très bien physique ton allure
dominante ta posture de caïds et on
s'extrait ou sont pour mépriser les
faibles du jouet
d'étincelles m
t
[Musique]
la virile et abusive justement c'est un
peu cet argent sur deux de se dire tu
dois c'est au même titre que tu dois
être dans la cuisine ma fille et tu dois
faire leur passage à xv à belleterre le
gars à cette pression sociale totale qui
dit que tu dois rouler des mécaniques
être costaud portel foyer subvenir à la
sécurité de sa famille au besoin il a
géré la sécurité et être apte à se
bagarrer à être puissant à être vaillant
et avec un ouais même avec un sexe
toujours bandant fort qui qui qui prône
un peu et qui définit un peu justement
cette virilité abusé qu'on se libère de
ça et qu'on puisse se dire si j'ai ce
penchant et si j'aime me tenir comme ça
ou avoir une voix plus efféminé ça fait
pas de moi quelqu'un et ça travaille pas
justement ça fait pas de moi quelqu'un
d'homosexuels ou pas justement ça l'air
et la voir sur la sexualité
je pense que c'est ça être un homme et
où être une femme aujourd'hui c'est
c'est pouvoir être libre de de ce qu'on
veut être et pas se dire ah ça ça à
partir à l'homme et ça ça appartient à
la femme